It's
already quite a mess from the road I
bought a soccer game over
there Boom
I brought an apple, but I ate
it and it seems I'll have to return before April 9
Even if it's art tomorrow, there's a big Saku store soon, so it's
hard for me, isn't it?  On the other hand
, I know that hiro wants to meet zero ii,
but I can't
agree with him If we meet, we won't be able to come back.
I don't want that,
so please, Hiro
, you can take care of me
, so don't go anywhere.
Sorry Ichigo,
Mitsuru told
me that I'm getting too involved in troublesome things
.
Yeah,
that's the good thing about the spaciousness
I've always been in the room on the left and right, so go
in.
Uh-oh, it
's okay, yeah,
it's pretty red
.
It
's a little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit